Speaker 1: All right. I want to
talk next about the things that
different people are doing in response
to what's going on with the coronavirus
pandemic. There are people who in their
place of business, if they control,
if they have a place of business and they
have control over what goes on, there
are saying my employees need to be vaccinated
or my customers need to be vaccinated or you
need a negative test if you're not vaccinated
or whatever. One Alabama doctor is now saying
he is not going to treat unvaccinated people. He
will not see unvaccinated patients in his office.
Dr. Jason Valentine is a physician at Mobile's
Diagnostic and Medical Clinic. Infirmary Health
posted a photo on his Facebook page showing him
next to a sign that says Effective October 1st.
Twenty twenty one, Dr. Valentine will no longer
see patients that are not vaccinated against
covid-19. Since posting the sign, Valentine
wrote, three unvaccinated patients asked where
they could get a vaccine. No conspiracy theories,
no excuses. Just where do they go? Valentine had
a blunt answer from those who asked him about his
decision. If they asked why, I told them covid is
a miserable way to die and I can't watch them die
like that, Valentine said. He's currently in the
process of mailing a letter to patients about
his decision. He posted a copy of the letter
online. We do not yet have any great treatments
for severe disease, he wrote. But we do have great
prevention with vaccines. Unfortunately,
many have declined to take the vaccine
and some end up severely ill or dead. I cannot
and will not force anyone to take the vaccine,
but I also cannot continue to watch my patients
suffer and die from an eminently preventable
disease. Therefore, as of October 1st, I will no
longer see patients that have not been vaccinated
against covid-19. If you wish to keep me as your
physician, documentation of your vaccination will
suffice. If you wish to choose another physician,
we will be happy to transfer your records. Now,
a bunch of people wrote to me about the story and
said, Isn't this a violation of the Hippocratic
Oath? Don't doctors have a duty to treat those
who are in need of treatment? And the answer is
yes. But this is not an emergency physician.
This is someone who this is primary care. This
is someone who's saying in my office, my roster
of patients will not include unvaccinated people.
And this is not emergency medicine. This is not
a doctor having someone showing up and needing to
be put on a ventilator in an emergency room.
And he says, now I'm going to look away. I'm
not going to provide you any treatment. This is
not emergency medicine. This is. Primary care,
so it's focusing on the Hippocratic
Oath aspect of this is not an honest
assessment of the situation. What we do need to
be thinking about here is that there is a burden
that is larger than it needs to be being placed
on the medical system, being placed on providers,
doctors, nurses and others. And it is a
perfectly reasonable thing to say. Wait a second,
if much of this the vaccine's not perfect, OK,
you could still get a case with the vaccine.
You could end up in the hospital. You could
end up dying even when vaccinated. But it
dramatically reduces your odds. So if we have
that as a possibility, what else can we be
doing? What else can doctors be doing to say the
burden needs to be reduced? Let's find a way to
encourage people to go and get vaccinated. Now,
I took a call on the show a couple of weeks ago
where the viewer actually said shouldn't when we
triage in an emergency room, take unvaccinated
people and triage them lower priority than
vaccinated people so that we don't say to the
person who got into a car accident, your treatment
will be delayed because of unvaccinated people.
And my answer was no, I don't see any way that you
do that legally. I don't see any way that you do
that morally or ethically from the standpoint
of when you're in an emergency room situation,
you're triaging based on severity and other
factors. And I don't think that that would make
sense. But increasingly, if primary care doctors
want to say, hey, listen, at my office, if you
want to be under my care, under primary care, if
you want to come in because you might have a sinus
infection or you have, you know, headache or you
have whatever reason people go into primary care,
you need to be vaccinated because I need to
reduce the burden, then that is something
that they can do. And many doctors could could do
this. And ultimately, people are going to have to
make a decision. Do I want to have a primary care
doctor and get the vaccine or do I want to remain
unvaccinated and maybe be unable to find one? Now,
of course, most primary care doctors are not going
to do this. So it's really academic to say what
if every primary care doctor did this? But good
for this doctor. This doctor is doing something
to try to encourage people to get vaccinated.
At least three of his patients have said, I'm
going to go and do it because I want to remain
under your care. Send me your thoughts about this,
as well as other ways that the medical community
could encourage people to go and get vaccinated.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We will be speaking very soon about our upcoming
one billion views on YouTube milestone. It's an
insane milestone for a show like ours. More
on that upcoming. Let's remember that The
David Pakman Show is independent media, funded
primarily by viewers and listeners like you,
you can sign up and support today through
the membership program at Join Pakman Dotcom,
and you do get some really great perks, including
commercial free audio and video streams of the
show every day. Access to the bonus show an
extra program every single day. The members
only newsletter, the occasional member only town
halls and so many other things. Grab a membership
and join Pakman Dotcom